Lately, I've been feeling this huge shift in energy
and this desire to simplify my life.
And I don't know if this is a reaction
to everything that's kind of going on in the news
and in the world, and with the election and all this stuff.
Just. It feels very unstable.
And I think
me and my husband have been talking a lot about simplifying our life,
kind of insulating, changing a chapter.
Potentially leaving Charleston.
We couldn't go too far because my husband owns a business in the area,
so we couldn't be that far away.
But where we live now is really busy.
We've watched the city change a lot.
And as much as we still love Charleston,
I think we're kind of feeling that time of our lives shift.
But what I find really interesting is we're feeling at the same time,
we both feel this push.
We don't know what the right direction to take is,
but we know that something has to give.
What? The lifestyle that we're living right now is unsustainable.
And I don't necessarily just mean financially.
The driving, a co ops,
the activities, him working like crazy,
everything just feels like a little bit too much right now.
Um, and we wanna kind of pair it back.
Like, look at what's really important to us,
look at the things that we wanna accomplish,
look at the lifestyle we wanna lead.
And with that comes this big sense of, like, anxiety.
Because we don't know the right thing to do right now.
So one of the things I did,
because I was getting really overwhelmed
with the homeschooling schedule,
is I took my kids out of co op just for December and January,
just for, like,
the two winter months.
They weren't even really gonna be in person anyway in January
because it's so cold, and they do it mostly outside.
So we're taking a break from that.
And I wrote down a schedule for my days with my kids
with homeschooling at home,
and I've gotten this, like,
huge sense of peace from it and productivity,
and the kids are also not as hectic and stressed,
and it's. It's actually been really great so far.
And another thing is,
I've taken a huge step back from certain personal relationships.
Um, if you've been following me a long time,
you know that my family has gone through a lot of UPS and downs with,
you know, toxic family structures and generational healing.
My mom is now starting her journey
of dealing with her generational trauma
from her mother,
which she so lovingly passed down to the three sisters,
me and my two sisters, so.
And I've always kind of been there and walked with everyone through it,
and they, you know,
certain members of my family have walked with me through mine.
But I'm taking a giant step back from the, like,
emotional labor of it. And again,
I've gotten this Huge sense of calm and peace from it,
because I don't feel a sense of expectation on me anymore.
And I always have.
I've always tried to meet these expectations and perform in some way.
Um, so I've been taking a step back,
but I've always been in tune.
I've always been in tune.
Me and my husband have always been aligned with our, like,
vision and our feelings and our desires for change when we want change
and desires to hunker when we wanna hunker.
So
both of us are feeling the push for a change and a chapter difference
and really re evaluating things.
And I don't know where it's gonna lead,
but something's brewing.
Something is pushing us in a different direction.
You can call it god, you can call it fate,
you can call it instinct, um,
but we have the tangles, and I'm interested to see how this shakes out.